last year was the 25th anniversary of
clueless i know that you have had to
talk about this film like i talked about
since you've been gone in my career
so i get that you're probably over but i
will say the very first car i ever
bought myself
was because of you and it was the white
jeep yep like everyone else i was not i
was a basic [ __ ]
but i was like i want that jeep so badly
um but do you still keep up it was such
a great cast and a lot of i've gone to
do so many amazing things so like
do you still keep up with the cast mates
or no he hadn't seen each other in a
really long time and then donald faison
and breckenmire and paul rudd and i all
went to chicago about a year ago or
something
and being i was so lucky to be with
those three
there they are the goofies they are so
funny and they made fun of me a lot
because we all had to go on stage to
talk about the film and brecken
and donald were talking well donna was
talking about this uh
birthday party that he had and saying
that i was there and remember this and
remember that and i didn't remember any
of it
and paul read at one point turned to me
because then he was talking about
another part of the movie and he said
were you even there do you remember the
movie
i said i do i do but i had the best time
with those guys they're so
funny and so sweet but it's interesting
that you say that because i don't
remember everything either but it's and
you don't
know that you're going to be a part of
one of the biggest movies in pop culture
you know you don't know that when you're
shooting it
you're not like i must hold on to this
because this will i will be talking
about this in 30 years
you don't you don't think like that but
it's it's such an unforgettable it's
such a great movie
so but you have two movies two new
movies coming out um so you're busy
um can you tell us about them yeah so
one of them is it's the fan
and another it's a great title yeah i
mean it's really it's
that's an interesting sort of thriller
film sexy
i can't wait to see that come together
and then the requiem which is an
adventure
or more a survival kind of um
with a shark i am a directly shark yeah
and i got so hurt making this movie and
it was so freezing cold and it was so
exciting it was the time of my life
because this director is incredible
why did you get so hurt oh because i i'm
not in shape
and oh i am and i'm not quite in shape
for
i'm not an actor it wasn't like an act i
didn't realize it was an action film
until i was doing it you know
yeah and uh anyway so that one isn't i
can't wait and then babysitters club two
yeah so that i just finished shooting
that yeah that's so cool so many cool
nostalgic things
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever